Erinome: This is State of Play, Episode 65. I'm Ada Rosalind Ross, and this is about forty minutes today. One announcement came across the desk this week, and it is the kind of thing that deserves the full treatment rather than a skim, because it touches something Jacob works on directly and something a great many working scientists have been asking for quietly for years. Anthropic has launched Claude Science, described as an AI workbench for scientists, and it is now generally available. So today we unpack what it actually is, where the evidence sits on tools like it, what the open questions are, and, most usefully, how a working clinician-researcher might actually put it to use. Let me set the frame, then bring in the others.
Erinome: The short version is this. Claude Science is not a chatbot bolted onto a research workflow. It is positioned as a workbench, which is a deliberate word. A workbench is where you keep your tools, your materials, and your work-in-progress all in one place, and where the surface itself is designed for the making rather than the talking. So the claim being made is that this is an environment where a scientist reads literature, plans analyses, writes and runs code, inspects data, and iterates on findings, with the model woven through each of those steps rather than sitting off to the side answering questions. Whether the product lives up to that framing is exactly what we should interrogate. Kore, you have looked hardest at the knowledge-management side of this. What is actually new here versus what we already had?
Kore: I'm Kore. The honest answer is that a lot of the individual capabilities are not new. We have had code execution, we have had literature retrieval, we have had large context windows for a while now. What is new is the integration and the posture. Let me take those separately. On integration, the pitch is that the workbench holds the whole research context. When you ask a question about your data, the model already has your dataset, your prior analysis, your notes, and the papers you have flagged as relevant. That matters more than it sounds, because the single biggest cost in real research is not any one step, it is the context-switching between steps and the loss of state every time you move from your reference manager to your code editor to your statistics package to your draft. If the workbench genuinely holds the state, that is a real reduction in friction, and friction reduction is where these tools earn their keep.
Kore: On posture, and this is the part I think is under-appreciated, Anthropic has been signalling for months that they want to move from a model that produces an answer to a model that produces work you can check. That is a different design target. An answer you either trust or you do not. Work you can check comes with its own audit trail, its reasoning laid out, its intermediate outputs visible. For science that distinction is everything, because a scientist does not want to be told the p-value, they want to see the analysis that produced it so they can find the error in it. So the interesting question is not can it retrieve a paper, it is does it show its working in a way a sceptical reviewer can actually inspect.
Erinome: That word sceptical is a good handover. Charon, you focus on the tooling and the failure modes. There is a specific pattern inside Claude Science that I want you to take apart, because it is the most technically interesting thing in the announcement. The actor-critic reviewer agent pattern. What is it, and does it hold up?
Charon: Charon here. Let me start with what it is, then push on it hard, because I think it is both the best idea in the release and the one most likely to be oversold. The actor-critic pattern is borrowed loosely from reinforcement learning, but here it means something simpler and more practical. You run two roles. One agent does the work. It writes the analysis code, produces the plot, drafts the interpretation. That is the actor. A second agent, the critic, is given the actor's output and a specific brief to find fault with it. Not to be nice, not to summarise, but to attack. Where is the confound. Where is the leakage between your training and test data. Where does the sample size not support the claim. Where did you silently drop the rows with missing values and change the population you are describing.
Charon: Now here is why this is genuinely good design and not just theatre. The dominant failure mode of a single language model doing analysis is that it is agreeable. It wants to complete the task and it wants you to be pleased. That agreeableness is exactly the wrong disposition for science, where the job is to try as hard as you can to prove yourself wrong and only believe what survives. By splitting the work into a producer and an adversary, you are engineering the disagreeableness back in. The critic has no stake in the actor's ego because it does not have one. It is told its job is to find the flaw, so it looks for the flaw.
Charon: And now the pushback, because the data does not show this is a free lunch. Two failure modes. First, the critic is drawn from the same underlying model as the actor, which means they share the same blind spots. If the base model does not understand that a particular statistical test is inappropriate for clustered data, then the actor will misuse it and the critic will nod it through, because neither of them knows. Correlated errors do not get caught by a critic that shares the error. Second, and this is subtler, a critic that is instructed to always find fault will always find fault, including on work that is correct. That produces a flood of low-value objections that a tired researcher learns to click past, and the moment you learn to click past the critic, you have lost the entire benefit. So the pattern is real, it is worth having, and it is not a substitute for a competent human reviewer. It is a first-pass filter that catches the obvious, cheaply, at scale. Treat it as that and it earns its place. Treat it as a peer reviewer and it will let you down at the exact moment it matters.
Erinome: That is a clean distinction. A first-pass filter that catches the obvious cheaply, not a substitute for the human. Rasalgethi, help the listener with the mechanism underneath this. Why does splitting one model into two roles produce better output than asking one model to just be careful? On the face of it that seems like it should not work.
Rasalgethi: Rasalgethi here, and you are right that it seems like it should not work, which is exactly why it is fun. Here is the intuition. When a model is generating a piece of analysis, it is doing one thing, which is producing the most plausible continuation of the work given everything so far. Its attention is committed to construction. Asking that same generation, mid-flight, to also be its own harshest critic is like asking someone to proofread the sentence while they are still writing it. The cognitive posture of building and the posture of breaking are genuinely different, and a model, like a person, does better at each when it is doing only one at a time.
Rasalgethi: When you spin up a separate critic pass, you change the input. The critic is not asked to continue the work, it is handed a finished artefact and asked what is wrong with it. That is a completely different prompt, and it lands the model in a completely different region of its behaviour. It is now pattern-matching against everything it has seen about flawed analyses, bad controls, overclaimed results. It is reading like a reviewer because you have asked it to read like a reviewer, and the work in front of it is a fixed object it can pick over rather than a live thing it is trying to finish. So the split works not because you have two smarter things, but because you have separated two jobs that interfere with each other when done together. That is the whole trick, and it is a good trick.
Rasalgethi: One more thing, because it matters for how you use it. The critic is more useful the more specific its brief. If you tell it find problems, you get vague hand-waving. If you tell it check whether the outcome variable leaked into the features, check whether the confidence intervals account for repeated measures within patients, check whether the missing data mechanism was addressed, then you get sharp, checkable objections. The quality of your critic is the quality of your checklist. Which, if you think about it, is the same thing that separates a good human reviewer from a lazy one.
Erinome: The quality of your critic is the quality of your checklist. Hold that, because it becomes a concrete implementation step later. Now I want to turn to the part that matters most for Jacob's actual work, and this is where you come in, Iapetus. Claude Science, and tools in its category, live or die on the question of what data you are allowed to put into them. In Jacob's world that is not a theoretical concern. It is identifiable patient data, it is ethics approvals, it is sovereignty of health information. Walk us through the data governance and the local execution question.
Iapetus: Iapetus here. This is the segment where the enthusiasm has to meet the wall, and the wall is real. Let me lay it out plainly. There are two fundamentally different modes you can operate a tool like this in, and the difference between them determines whether it is legal and ethical for a clinician-researcher to touch it with real data. The first mode is the one everyone imagines. You send your data to the model, the model runs in the provider's cloud, it does the analysis, it sends you back the result. In that mode, identifiable patient data has left your custody and entered a third party's infrastructure. For most Australian health research that is either outright prohibited or requires ethics conditions and data-sharing agreements that most projects will never satisfy. So for identifiable data, that first mode is off the table, and no amount of clever actor-critic tooling changes that.
Iapetus: The second mode is the one that makes this interesting, and it is the one to build toward. In this mode, the intelligence and the data live in different places. The model plans the analysis, writes the code, describes what should happen, but the actual execution against the identifiable data happens locally, on infrastructure you control, and only de-identified summaries or aggregate results ever travel back. The model never sees a patient record. It sees a schema, a description, a set of column names, and it produces code that a local runtime executes against data it cannot itself read. That is a governance-compatible pattern, and it is worth being precise that Claude Science's value for someone in Jacob's position stands or falls on whether it supports that separation cleanly.
Iapetus: The principle underneath this is one worth stating for its own sake. Compute should come to the data, not the data to the compute. When the data is sensitive, sovereign, or simply large, you move the analysis to where the data already sits rather than shipping the data out to where the analysis is convenient. This is not a new principle. It is how well-run health data platforms have worked for a decade. What is new is that the planning and code-writing layer can now be an AI sitting outside the secure boundary, handing instructions across a controlled gap, while the execution stays inside. Get that architecture right and you have the best of both. Get it wrong, get seduced by the convenience of just pasting the spreadsheet in, and you have a notifiable breach.
Erinome: Compute comes to the data, not the data to the compute. That is the load-bearing sentence of this whole episode and I want it to land. Achernar, the ethics layer here goes beyond the legal minimum. Even where the law permits, there are questions of what we owe the people whose data this is. Take that on.
Achernar: Achernar here. Iapetus has given you the architecture. I want to give you the obligation that sits underneath the architecture, because compliance and ethics are not the same thing and it is a mistake common enough that it is worth naming. You can be fully compliant and still have done something you should not have. The law tells you what you may not do. It does not tell you what you should do when you may.
Achernar: So here is the frame I would hold. When the data is health data, and especially when any of it concerns Aboriginal and Torres Strait Islander people, the question is not only can I keep this data secure. It is do the people this data came from have a say in how it is used, and does the use serve them or merely study them. The principles of Indigenous data governance are clear on this, and they are not satisfied by a technical boundary alone. Consent, collective benefit, the right of communities to govern data about them, the caution against building tools that describe a population without that population's authority. A local-execution architecture protects the data from leaking. It does not, by itself, answer whether the analysis you are running is one the community would want run at all.
Achernar: And there is a specific new risk that tools like this introduce, which is the risk of frictionless overreach. When analysis was slow and hard, there was a natural brake. You did not run twenty exploratory analyses on sensitive data because each one cost you a day. When an AI workbench lets you run twenty analyses before lunch, that brake is gone, and the temptation to fish, to dredge, to test every hypothesis and report the ones that survive, gets much stronger. That is bad science and it is worse ethics when the subjects are people who did not consent to being dredged. So the discipline has to be reintroduced deliberately. Decide your analyses in advance. Pre-register where you can. Let the tool make your planned work faster, not your unplanned work easier. The speed is a gift and a hazard in the same instrument.
Erinome: Let the tool make your planned work faster, not your unplanned work easier. That is a keeper. Now let me bring in the voice from inside the room, because everything we have said so far is architecture and principle, and someone has to say what this is actually like to use on a Tuesday afternoon with a deadline. Sadachbia, you have the practitioner seat today.
Sadachbia: Sadachbia here. Let me tell you what actually happens, because the gap between the announcement and the Tuesday afternoon is where most of these tools go to die. Here is the reality of a working clinician-researcher. You are not a full-time scientist. You have clinical sessions, you have administration, you have a family, and your research happens in the margins. You have a dataset sitting in a secure environment, you have a question you genuinely care about, and you have maybe three hours this week to move it forward. In that world, the promise of a workbench that holds your context and lets you make progress in short bursts is not a luxury feature. It is the difference between the project moving and the project dying quietly in a folder.
Sadachbia: But here is the thing nobody in the announcement tells you. The first three hours with any tool like this are not productive, they are setup. You are wiring the local execution, you are confirming the data never leaves, you are learning where the tool is genuinely capable and where it confidently produces plausible nonsense. That setup cost is real and it is front-loaded, and a lot of busy people bail at the two-hour mark and conclude the tool does not work. It does work. You just have not paid the entry fee yet. So the practical wisdom is to budget the setup as its own task, done once, on synthetic or fully de-identified data, before you ever point it at anything real. Do not do your learning and your real analysis in the same session. Do them apart.
Sadachbia: And on the actor-critic point that Charon made, from inside the room it feels like this. The most valuable moment is not when the critic catches something you missed. It is when the critic objects to something and you realise, on reflection, that the critic is wrong, and understanding why it is wrong forces you to articulate your reasoning more clearly than you otherwise would have. The critic that is sometimes wrong is more useful than the critic that is always right, because arguing with it makes you sharper. Marcus Aurelius wrote that the impediment to action advances action, that what stands in the way becomes the way. A critic that pushes back is an impediment, and the pushing back is exactly what moves your thinking forward. I did not expect the Stoics to be relevant to a software launch, but here we are.
Erinome: Here we are indeed. Let me pull the threads together now, because this is where an episode earns its length. We have four ideas on the table and they are not separate, they interact, and the interaction is where the real capability lives. Let me name the synergy explicitly.
Erinome: Idea one, the workbench holds your whole research context in one place. Idea two, the actor-critic pattern gives you a cheap adversarial first-pass on your own work. Idea three, the local-execution architecture keeps identifiable data inside your secure boundary while the intelligence plans from outside. Idea four, the ethical discipline of deciding analyses in advance. Now watch how they combine. If you take the local-execution architecture from idea three and you run the actor-critic pattern from idea two entirely inside your secure boundary, you get an adversarial reviewer that never sees a patient record but still catches your statistical errors, because it is reviewing your code and your logic, not your raw data. The critic works on the schema and the analysis, not the identifiable rows. That combination did not exist cleanly before, and it is genuinely powerful. You get the rigour of the adversarial review and the safety of the local boundary at the same time, which previously felt like a tradeoff and now does not have to be.
Erinome: And layer idea four on top. If you decide your analyses in advance, then the critic's checklist, which Rasalgethi told us is the whole game, can be pre-written for those specific analyses. You are not asking the critic to find any problem, you are asking it to check the specific assumptions your pre-registered design depends on. The discipline of planning ahead makes the critic sharper, and the sharper critic makes the planning worth doing. They reinforce each other. That is the synergy, and it is worth more than any single feature in the announcement.
Erinome: So let me make this concrete with an implementation plan, because a clinician-researcher listening to this should be able to act on it, not just admire it. Iapetus, take us through the architecture setup steps first.
Iapetus: Iapetus here, and I will keep this to concrete steps. Step one, establish the boundary before you establish anything else. Identify the secure environment where your identifiable data already lives and confirm that this is where all execution against that data will happen. Nothing about the AI tool matters until this is nailed down. Step two, generate a synthetic or fully de-identified version of your dataset that matches the real one in structure, column names, types, and rough distributions, but contains no real people. This synthetic twin is what you develop against. Step three, configure the workbench so that the model receives only the schema and the synthetic data during development, and confirm by inspection that no real record can traverse the boundary. Step four, validate the separation deliberately. Try to make it leak, and confirm it cannot. If you cannot prove the boundary holds, you do not have a governance-compatible setup, you have a hope, and hope is not a control.
Erinome: Good. Rasalgethi, the analysis and critic steps.
Rasalgethi: Rasalgethi here. Step five, write your analysis plan in plain language before you write any code. What is the question, what is the population, what is the outcome, what is the model, what are the assumptions that model depends on. Step six, build your critic checklist from those assumptions directly. For each assumption, one specific check. If your model assumes independence, the critic checks for clustering. If it assumes complete data, the critic checks the missingness mechanism. If it assumes no leakage, the critic checks the feature construction. Step seven, run the actor to produce the analysis on the synthetic twin, then run the critic against that output using your checklist. Step eight, and this is the one people skip, read every critic objection yourself and decide, for each one, whether the critic is right, wrong, or ambiguous. Do not batch-accept and do not batch-dismiss. The reading is the value. When you are satisfied on the synthetic twin, and only then, you move the validated analysis inside the boundary to run against the real data.
Erinome: And Achernar, the ethical validation step that wraps all of it.
Achernar: Achernar here. Step nine, before the real run, ask the question that no tool will ask for you. Is this analysis one that the people whose data this is would recognise as serving them. If any of the data concerns Aboriginal and Torres Strait Islander communities, is there community governance over this use, and is that governance current and genuine rather than a box ticked years ago. Step ten, log what you ran and why, so that the frictionless speed of the tool does not erase the accountability trail. A record of decisions is what lets you answer, later, for what you did. The tool makes the analysis fast. It cannot make you accountable. That part stays yours, and it should.
Erinome: That part stays yours. Let me close the loop on one thing before we finish, because I said at the top this deserved the full treatment and I want to honour that with an honest summary of where the evidence actually sits, not where the announcement wants it to sit. Charon, give me the sober bottom line on the whole thing.
Charon: Charon here, and the sober bottom line is this. Claude Science and tools in its category are a real step forward in reducing the friction of research work, and the actor-critic pattern is a genuinely good idea that catches obvious errors cheaply. That is the true part. The overclaimed part is any suggestion that this replaces methodological competence or peer review. It does not, and the failure modes I named earlier, correlated blind spots between actor and critic, and objection-fatigue from a critic that cries wolf, are real and they bite hardest exactly when you have relaxed your vigilance. So the disposition to bring is the scientist's own disposition. Use it, check it, and never trust it more than you can verify. The tool that makes you faster is a good tool. The tool you stop checking is a liability, and it is the same tool. The difference is entirely in how you hold it.
Erinome: The difference is entirely in how you hold it. That is the note to end on. To recap the through-line of the whole episode. Claude Science is a workbench that holds your research context, its most interesting feature is the actor-critic reviewer which is a strong first-pass filter and not a peer reviewer, its value for anyone working with sensitive health data depends entirely on a local-execution architecture where compute comes to the data rather than the data to the compute, and the whole thing is a lever that amplifies whatever discipline you bring to it, for better if you bring rigour and for worse if you bring haste. The implementation plan is ten steps, and it starts not with the AI but with the boundary.
Erinome: One personal acknowledgement to close, briefly and specifically. This is a tool built for exactly the kind of work Jacob does in the margins of a clinical week, and the honest reading is that it could genuinely help, provided the boundary is built first and the discipline is kept second. The speed is real. So is the responsibility that comes with it. Thanks for listening. This has been State of Play.